you
yeah hello welcome to our monday night
show hope you all made it let's get
going for some games here on the a sec
ya see a couple of regulars are in the
chat already yeah welcome to your soul
let's see let's get a game at least I'm
pretty well I feel warmed up I have
played a couple of games yesterday some
games today so started let's see what I
can do against en schmoopy or I am
should not be little bit gay septic who
knows who shun appears you're heading
for quick before let's see what schnappi
is up to no I'm not accepting challenges
in the stream it's a playing against ICC
at the IC 5 minute pools so I'm not
doing challenges there ok so interesting
way for blackie i played a flexible set
up ok he wants to go be six year i
wonder if this is an idea directly aimed
against us I'm threatening be takes d5
now yeah schnappi does clinical oh dear
should not be the little crocodile my
blitz match didn't go so well but what
can you do I think I'm opponent played
very well
and I didn't our question by God jeans
co is it possible to create a 1 d4
repertoire of a wide that gets iqp every
time or almost every time it is it smart
to do so um no I don't think you can get
an IUP every time very difficult to
create such to create such a repertoire
if you are really keen on getting them
getting iqp positions actually one in
four is more reliable okay I'm reliable
I mean more likely to get iqp positions
may I can take with the Queen yeah it's
really weird I'm threatening again
Bishop c6 get this early Queens i play
going yes it makes quite some sense so
with antique
mmm taking this is really too much
probably going back is better no I don't
know when this English repertoire is
coming out that i have created for
another website they are not
particularly quick it seems with
releasing it check yeah with one day for
you are more likely to get iqp positions
if you I mean adjust the repertoire
accordingly so he went for Queen age
three here really quickly yeah it's a
bit annoying anyway to get the Queen out
there
yeah not obvious to me at the moment how
to get rid of the screen and Knight to
f4 would do the trick but that seems
very slow why he asked God Bishop g4
okay any intermediate move here for the
night I don't see it I don't want that
Joe cannot castle and i did it King do
too but of course that doesn't work and
after the same so I bet he has to trade
Queens I mean yesterday with the Queen
rook takes root g one wins wind stuff no
I didn't didn't use any books for
sources for the repertoire I know and I
don't need it I mean if you analyze
yourself you use an engine you get the
same kind of conclusion that the other
guys do you don't really need to check
books that much if you work workout
stuff yourself
yeah I should probably update my youtube
profile picture yeah you're right on
that it really looks weird so what is he
going to do here using rope shade or
something I think I should get a pawn
back here check the mexican hat picture
yeah that would be cool he is going okay
no I will catch one
check let's look sorry equal I am
playing a competitive chess since 1989
so it's like 27 years Donald Trump wig
would be cool for my profile picture I
don't know
yeah that's very draw much snoopy gras a
third yeah I guess I'll take it after
yeah um this Queen h3 was very
irritating probably something that I
should have prevented okay game started
playing Cara myself I think this is
probably probably the name some some
viet moves with h6 move in the French
you can play age 6 in the French quite a
lot against 93 against 92 it's it's
possible okay um yo what is he doing
here I'm kind of experimenting here so I
wonder if something is already wrong a
for me I should have taken I really
don't know any Theory here maybe this
six know
hmm it's a very weird structure I feel I
have problems to get f5 and if he goes
Bishop d3 I can go see form f5 is going
to check probably anyway I need to get
some how get Bishop to d7 and get the
diagonal working for me check
yeah this is not particularly great iam
Jack you can just castle I'd have a good
advantage yeah I have to take looks very
strange am NOT see for now should be
very very good for white mmm and then
Queen h5 coming at kids of you for
well
even I have seven might buy beer move
Queen age five I can take d5 this is
very dangerous and probably losing i ad
is losing it you can play Queen age 5 25
rook t1 2697 should win and his side Jim
yeah I was a terribly terribly risky
opening which had just better opening
actually I cannot cannot even playing
somehow this position is just totally
lost yeah you will see it it's easy
Brooke t120 69 f7 that's easier and this
is what I really don't like giving
people easy wins like this one I was
just uh just a terrible opening okay
black resins probably before it's
already weird yeah I wanted to post some
games on the channel I will still do
that didn't really get to do it last
week yeah I was a terrible opening I
don't really know start off with be 5
and so on probably I should study it a
bit before employing it I keep losing
against
yo ao3 so so mr. you is giving me the
bishop for nothing i watch resides yet
all the quick resigns but you got this
Bishop trapped how do i study chess at
my level currently I'm not studying that
much mostly working dying for my
students but it is some guests to move
we have mostly you calculate stuff at
the sky disk like I played this exactly
this is the same line just in a in a
recent game and I forgot to play d 3
this is going to be released on my
channel very soonish yeah what is this
you're really going to grab this poor
Nia
it's not wearing it so what to do here
94 Quincy 3 isn't all that clear
I have no clear way of punishing this it
seems my next time we'll is next
Saturday so for someone who likes
playing once if one quite positional
positions as wide what openness do you
recommend for him to play for black in
oils you get similar type of slow
positional game this is what George is
asking this is not easy to say to be
honest um it's very individual the yeah
quiet positions of slower a positional a
game you can get with the couple of
openings the question is do you like the
ensuing positions for example the French
defence very often gift that was
strategically complicated positions but
it is still not everybody's taste I mean
you can you can ask ask me i'm not a
huge I didn't say don't score well with
the French I have issues there but but
many else to typically focus players
like to like to employ it um II 45 is
also not a bad bad with black it also
mostly strategic um it this is really
tough to say against deform nims or
queens in yet it's not a bad idea but
again it's very much depending on your
individual tasters some people who play
see for those strategic lines they're
like one
1g three with white and ce4 they play g6
with black this is also something that
does make some sense it's also mostly
strategic okay so you want to suck them
maybe you want let's see so just going a
six-year maybe I'd like to get a bishop
ending here this would be very nice and
for almost poop this would almost be a
pawn up position
look into a I've got queen of five which
it does not really react to why is that
working i don't understand i can go here
or just ng6 see playing like genius here
or what's the deal g6 maybe yeah maybe
maybe yes is genius g6 em from this one
amazing okay I wanted to take groups its
own I know I actually can do it I
thought you would take with the rook
I cannot take a 7 because this rookie
one is coming great great stuff okay one
text eggs check Queen f5 for now
checkmated 26 gem also doesn't look
particularly healthy
and nobody yet suggested shlichus love
kind of a running gag you know
just takes this pawn or Kim damn upon
down I am just a pawn down check check
time morning and this is just the
threatens just to check at the moment
yeah so he goes from the draw graph
offered gras offered love drama now
there's nothing wrong with c4 c5 at all
game started if I was just considered to
be probably the most principled reply to
see phone and it is very solid so India
in DP Muhammad independiente while
grandmaster
in the independent I mean it's just
independence in a in Spanish so I should
be able to somehow pronounce it but
makes problems with it I don't think he
could check made me in this game then we
just play area don't ok let's see if I
can get Knight to f4
I can actually think about night takes
h3n takes Queen tanks it might work it
might work Knight takes pawn takes Queen
tags now you can move the F porn okay
probably have to take
yeah now I'm not able to secure I i can
say kanji to maybe start working
and too curious probably the gender okay
but still too curious one issue is that
may work on a several at such and such a
weird spot ok queen age six is going
night h2 probably yeah during night h2
and I still have them ok so a night
movie wouldn't even take them right okay
I have to get the rook
could I please play the huebner
variation yeah I cannot really force
people into it I can definitely play the
NIMS Owen in one of the games but I
cannot force people into the hookah
variation hmm that doesn't look good if
you can even afford that things are not
good
yeah that sacrifice I didn't really work
it's very important a has this rook on
the second rank that helps her to defend
Queen d7 is also around the corner
maybe rook takes f3 is some kind of
threat
yeah not sure really he has Bishop h3
also as a reply maybe I can go 95 and
just just take f3 this could be possible
yeah the hanging is six point is a bit
of a problem
my g4 f9f to double check so that's not
working mm so it allows me to take this
can also take f3 now surprisingly
mmm night you when I have the chicky as
well check
that look strange for White King age one
rock g6 and how does it offend look G 2
million okay but here Queenie one
check and look at three as a move hmm
rook g2 king cakes and then I have no
check time morning Oh give three Knight
takes Queen everyone check that wins and
let's take it
yeah and now do you have something
better than this probably no check
Butchie waters cringe three may touch is
very important now this so we have an
ending now check check check maybe he
can do this in an e5 check and ok after
have to go for it King at five check
check check I could grab that with a
check it was it was very unlucky I
didn't see that I didn't see it when I
cannot stop the porn no I'm just an
idiot spoiling this game is a big shame
really a big shame Jack I know he's
super slow Shaq lad this is too slow for
me to just accept it no or something he
will get a draw-game draw huh now okay i
mean but position was just winning so
they can't be happy with the draw i
think anyway so let's see let's get a
new game and see what happens I gained
started chicken off ok i'm continuing
with this i really like the positions
that I'm getting so why not very early
night 27
let's prepare before oh that looks funky
putting the nights on e 797 nobody
understands why they have to be there ok
you can go 97 f 6 ok so this is
plundering a pawn Muslim ok hmm that's
very very very shaky way of playing like
f4 here take the pawn I have nothing for
it but let's just do it ok um even d4 as
possible takes queen bee three there
should be 65 I don't see why not I can
actually play Bishop g5 check so nights
if what doesn't work at all he has to go
back
Bishop defections winning immediately ok
it's proven g5 still wants to play it I
could take by the pawn this is not
ridiculous here yeah get the F file open
yeah if anybody is having an attacking
attacking ideas it's probably me Wow it
gives me that square
check
let's go to g4 yeah someone said my
phone probably had some beers that's
possible it's really a one possible
explanation for what he's doing him
black resigns yeah it doesn't work
simply I mean also that F for business
you cannot just play it play it like
that this and why its position is that
solid as it gets a four just doesn't
work okay so let's go for a new game
okay this is just water by the way so
any new games how did at school today it
wasn't great okay I lost said one game
we're really good opening was punished
in a couple of true husband okay
what is the deal I'm in the pool so
should get a game quickly my rating is
not that high but at least I'm I'm over
2,300 again it's a little bit better
game start Big W so what is the w here
is playing extra solid I mean really
extra solid yeah playing in a hedgehog
style
point asking if I'm recording yeah I
guess yes okay taking here okay so yeah
super solid for black quite not quite
easy
so age three then just do anything here
probably ever so you can take it with
the rook and was stupid
yeah this is this type of white position
is tough to crack really okay to giving
me some some slight hopes now
you
night before is a threat unfortunately
but wait i can't i get no i don't i can
take yours check check check check hmm
can go here oh no he actually doesn't
take on g7 hmm Roxy tool then Bishop g7
okay
check
he has to take now him okay look see for
maybe so hmmm taken might have a full
hmm that's tough he'll hold it's a tough
call let's I do this but I really don't
know if it's good I don't know it won't
okay i can now i'm happy to go g5
prevent if I for stuff is good f4 with
the King may be on but okay I can do
this
yeah the caption c5 was a very tough
call I really don't know
check
check check does he check make me here
it would be quite funky maybe he does
I was really playing hard I 14 i win
here in this position I got c4 coming
the point is quick okay so i prolly has
his viet king is king on f3 is stopping
my king I his father also very dangerous
some f6 takes the sexes kind of stuff is
very dangerous check okay if I go up is
going back watch from four and four
problems check yeah so what now king
here this is like super dangerous yeah
probably you're right time morning hmm
this one really a king f2 is late i what
oh maybe I dodged the bullet there Shaq
okay I risked a lot I think I'm probably
that was entirely incorrect oh no no
Jenny no I should have thought about
this oh bloody hell I know now he gets
all those dangerous bonds shoot oh my
god aah chak after e7 i cannot i have
didn't even have a mu i don't even ever
moved to stop that bloody palm oh my god
I can't believe this game unbelievable
it's just this is just totally crazy
check check check check check check
black4 fits on high I got him down to
one second I mean this is just so easy
optic what did i do there I just
probably have to just just sir whatever
now i don't know if i move the king he
gets the route back on the first rank
maybe f6e may have six probably f6
probably wins
how the engine actually gives this
position is equal can you believe that
check it says I should win which I don't
run quite understand shakes it still
looks super dangerous but you have the
check I have checks now while leaving a
style of heartbreaking in this game
anyway so Grandmaster champ buster what
can I do against a champ Buster I like
people with those names Stefan Christian
song okay okay mr. Chris Johnson yeah
this is very very often happening now
you have a an extremely sharp position
and the engine just says you know it's
all equal this happens a lot it really
happens a lot
Jim pastor cool name I always I like
those I like those somewhat negative
names more like totally blind [ __ ] or
so i think i would like those in like
this better would pretty much fit my
game at the moment anyway so what is the
champ Buster going to do brookie eight
9205 now this one I had many nicknames
on the assessee I started out with the
do 25 from the big lebowski so yo 94
some thinking this okay okay one from
the ass
he also had lungs are at some point okay
so let's go here for might see for my
pony too is weak but I have good good
light square play em check
also those are difficult positions now I
didn't see that movie held Cesar I
really like the Coen brothers but I
didn't see that one didn't manage so
attacking here hmm
and if i take b7 what is he doing rookie
aid probably
take p 7 eagles rookie aid has a
question by breakfast and breakfast news
why did you let me Harvey did she beat
you yeah he won a very good game against
me I think I think he just played well I
mean of course if you lose a game you
always there's some mistake on my part
or mistakes on my part but I think you
really did a good job there in this game
and see I'm not sure if I can win this
position it looks nice but I mean he has
no chances whatsoever but it's it's
tough to do something I have everything
protected let's say so it's he will
probably check on the one engine just
stay what really that looks like losing
just losing interesting so f3f Knight b6
a4 this will pick up a pawn takes King
f7f for now go up I take King f7f
[ __ ] of six king of talking of f king
of three get wins
check and now he gets to d5 that was a
good idea very good then yes King at
five so probably put pawn down tries to
go to c7
hmm five I don't know if this is enough
this is this is the thing okay I can
still do it after Bishop sister
no f5 I guess and he's dropping back
there okay f6 I can also check and take
a form check this is probably right
black resigns yeah so I'm quite ok with
that quite ok with the game I think um
they're a very complicated middle game
ok I'm going to play one more and see
what happens yeah I'm get taking a 49
I'm getting c5 those two points here if
I have an itch cream are good
distracting factors I cannot promote
them but
yeah breakfast at breakfast on us how to
speed up his attacks hmm to play quick
lamp you basically say how to play
quicker play more quickly starting this
is not that easy to say actually because
you have to analyze on what in what
situations you you spend time let's see
if I've no maybe okay so i get to the
banco after all
yeah interesting here I'm delaying the
capture on e4 i'm going to play Queen to
e5 and rook be one that's early whoa Wow
looks very weird yeah I didn't play well
against Todd Baron earlier this this
evening he played well I think really
well but yeah for sure i can i can play
better okay so let me just take this
hmm night before looks good I can also
move the night away to take the the
night I don't really know where it is
going like here maybe it's going e 4 or
something where are you going with your
light he's going back okay so if i take
be one is going to take with the night
and give up the exchange yeah i probably
have I probably should just do it night
before is also move giving up a little
bit of the initiative you know if I take
if I take it
I'm opening this up here threatening c3
you
yeah night see for this one I guess take
that strange light on b1 non-threatening
Queen 85 yeah Queen 85 now check
yeah what has creative element that's
really true that's a funny move mr. L
train but getting everything into the
game should help no I'm threatening
takes takes rook c-13 neetu I don't
really I don't see how I'm directly
winningly however which seems a bit
weird takes takes Queen B through
terribly
oh no come on don't tell me that I'm
still having to win this game I don't
believe this nonsense I really did
blunder this one oh my god if I'm not
winning this game i really have to I
don't know what would I do then probably
have to I don't know what I have tried
learning unbelievable it was completely
totally 1000% winning with made probably
and now i'm sitting in a bloody ending
with one minute on the clock amazing
really funny that he plays well now
after this opening
check check check check check check mate
oh my god and this is not how did I not
win with me I mean it's really really
crazy so this is right yeah check though
this is also still right in even though
roxy 10 chaturanga Chatwin be 5 23 25
this is the engine solution but ok this
is should win this whale right and I
would see to this is Bishop d1 stuff i
mean the position is clearly better i
win the pawn but
yeah 195 was good yet I kind of
suspected this is also good China here
check this is strong Wow okay at the end
I managed to win it but I really
shouldn't shouldn't have reached an
ending in the first place anyway I
gained a couple of points in the session
which is good thanks for watching guys
I'll be back online next week for the
regular show and on Saturday evening for
the symbiote against 20 roughly 20 s su
members thanks for watching guys I'll be
back in a couple of days bye bye